[Music]
the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
welcome to the bonus show i only briefly
mentioned this today
uh on the regular show but we learned
that former republican presidential
candidate herman cain has died of
coronavirus
it has not been i mean i guess we don't
know for sure
but he was diagnosed not long after
attending donald trump's
unmasked tulsa oklahoma rally
and it is at least reasonable to suspect
pat
that he caught the virus attending that
rally
and there's pictures of him on social
media there and you know i i saw that
there were some people like gren glean
glenn greenwald tweeted it's despicable
to see people on the left gleefully
gushing about the death of herman cain
i'm not seeing anybody gleefully gushing
about the death of herman cain i'm
seeing people
post things like this is tragic and it's
real
that rally was totally optional and it
seems as though people are dying because
of a political stunt that's that's not
gleeful in any way
yeah we don't want anyone to die from
coronavirus we also don't need anyone to
die
from coronavirus to justify the position
that trump needs to get voted out
even before all this started even before
the economic meltdown started
we had a case to get rid of donald trump
in november 2020
this is just more reason it feels and
it's not like i'm happy over herman cain
dying i don't want anyone to die
but it just goes to show that it was
idiotic for trump to hold this rally
because it was so dangerous to do
and it probably led to plenty of people
getting the virus
some of which are going to die and that
was foreseeable at the time we were
calling out the rally at the time he
shouldn't be doing this
and now trump has changed his tune you
know now he's apparently taking the
virus seriously so is that like an
admission that he shouldn't have held
those rallies
a month or two ago um of course he'll
never apologize he'll never
uh you know treat it as if he actually
does have blood on his hands
because that's what trump does but to
make that case
is pretty clear i think well he has
stopped doing the rallies that's one
sign he has announced they're not going
to do the big republican national
convention that's another sign
but even that i mean we had the report i
think it was early this week or maybe
late last week
that the reason trump is changing his
tune is just that he's told republicans
are dying
our people was the word his advisors
reportedly used our people
are getting sick and dying and that it
just goes back to getting himself
reelected and i was talking to somebody
yesterday
and they were saying doesn't it seem
like trump doesn't even want to do this
anymore and on some level i do think
trump doesn't want to do this anymore
but his narcissism won't allow him to
accept just losing
in other words he probably is sick of
the job
at this point but the being the most
powerful man in the world or whatever
uh and the possibility of of suffering
an embarrassing defeat is what's keeping
him motivated and a cornered trump is a
dangerous trump and we're seeing it and
i mean did trump kill herman cain in
some kind of
a vague sense like is that a crazy thing
to say in this case
i mean it's certainly not a one-to-one
it's certainly like it's not as if trump
took a gun and shot herman cain no
i mean he you know he caused this chain
of events that led to herman cade's
death and it was foreseeable and we knew
that it was reckless for him to do so
it's i mean maybe similar to something
like i don't know it's like seem like
manslaughter is that too far
because like his actions led to death
that was like foreseeable and like
that's usually the standard that's
applied in the in the law firm yeah
i i don't know i mean obviously i don't
literally think
trump killed herman cain trump holding
the rally doesn't mean herman cain has
to go either right like we can't absolve
the fact if indeed he got it at the
rally nobody
forced herman cain to go to the rally so
so i'm not saying this in a literal
sense but
that was a completely optional event
this wasn't someone who
was at work and and and got the virus
right this was a propaganda
rally a large crowd which you're not
supposed to do at a time when cases were
starting to surge in tulsa i don't know
what the answer is but it's tragic
i don't i haven't seen as of yet anybody
on the left
gleefully gushing about it and you're
absolutely right that
what's hap we don't need anything else
to go wrong to justify removing trump
and certainly the idea from people like
don jr has spread this idea that the
left
wants cases and deaths in order to hurt
trump politically
nobody on the left that i've seen wants
that nobody has seriously made that case
and most importantly
we don't need it because what's happened
is already bad enough period
full stop yeah and left-wingers can also
die from the virus so the argument
doesn't even make sense
no uh russia's aiming to approve a
coronavirus vaccine
within weeks but the country has not yet
released any data about vaccine
tests this is according to a report from
cnn earlier this week
and what we know is that russian
officials are hoping to gain
approval for a vaccine developed by a
moscow-based
medical research lab gamalea institute
by august 10th once it's approved
frontline healthcare workers will be the
first to receive the vaccine
much like is expected to be the case
here in the united states
and um how much of this is true i have
no idea now i do want to say something
you can find articles including one
about in fact i have it on my phone
i have this app pocket where i put
articles i want to read
there's an article in
technologyreview.com
called some scientists are taking a
do-it-yourself coronavirus vaccine
and nobody knows if it's legal or if it
works and geneticist george church who
we've interviewed is involved in this
there are widespread reports of
very small scale um developments
by people who have access to labs
of supposed vaccines now if you're
willing to just give yourself something
and you have the
the resources and the know-how to
develop something that
is it's an injection whether it's
actually a vaccine or not is a is a
different question but it's something
you can inject
you can go ahead and try it and what i'm
trying to figure out is
on the one hand you've got diy vaccine
people doing stuff in the u.s on the
other hand you have things that are
going on like
oxford universities vaccine moderna
pfizer etc
where on that spectrum does this vaccine
that russia
may soon approve lie is it closer to the
backyard vaccine
is it closer to what moderna and oxford
are doing i genuinely have no idea
yeah it's hard to say and i know you've
been asked like if a vaccine for
coronavirus was developed in israel
would you take it or if
vaccine was developed in china would you
trust it um and you
are willing to take that right i mean if
it doesn't really matter where the
country what the country is doesn't
really matter i mean listen
it doesn't matter to me politically but
what matters is what degree of
confidence do i have
in the research and medical system of
the country
what data do we have about the testing
is the data reliable but
i guess what i my point was i'm putting
political
considerations aside yeah i suppose you
just have to ask yourself if you would
trust
uh the methodology and the studies if
they're coming out from a corrupt
country like russia
um but also i mean it's kind of a moot
point anyway because we're not going to
be the first in line to get a
coronavirus vaccine anyway it's
not the one that russia makes certainly
yeah it would probably go to russian
citizens and then you know even if it
does get to here it would go to the
medical community it would go to the
at-risk population so it's really not
even a question that we have to answer
uh but i feel as though i'm certainly
not an anti-vaxxer or anything like that
but i feel like i would probably want a
few million people to take the vaccine
before
millions feel comfortable i think so
yeah you don't think that for example in
phase 3 trials typically 30 or 40 000
is a number that is that is widely
considered statistically significant
that wouldn't you want millions of
people
well maybe maybe tens of thousands is
okay it's also a question of like
how long after they take the vaccine
do we know that it's for sure safe and
then there's not gonna be any like
negative consequences so i'd wanna give
it some time also
so russia's vaccine still needs to
finish phase two of testing
that is expected to be done by i guess
it would be monday
and then phase three will start but they
want to start giving the vaccine to
frontline healthcare workers
as they do a phase three test and i mean
i guess if the workers aren't being
forced and they want to do it it's
certainly a decision that i'm okay with
them making i would just want to
understand what the details are and what
the risks are
do you think that there's a chance that
we get a vaccine before this second wave
in the fall
or do you think that even if it gets
developed it's not even going to have
much of an impact on the trajectory
because we're not going to be able to
scale it up
and have enough people vaccinated to to
stop the second wave so
there's this on spec production being
done of the top vaccine candidates where
before we know
for sure whether we can use it in large
numbers they're going to start producing
it and that's that's
commonly done and that's the right thing
to do the estimates now
are that you wouldn't really have a
significant amount of doses until
very close to the end of the year so
if i had to give you my best guess right
now i do believe that
sometime around october 15th or november
1st
there will be a vaccine that is safe
enough and effective enough provides at
least
some months of immunity that there will
be a go-ahead for people to start
getting it
but i think the doses until the very end
of december will be very very minimal
and of course from the standpoint of
both the election and wave
two which i don't even know that there's
a gap between wave one and two
i don't think it's going to have an
impact because i think it's all going to
be after that
yeah very interesting timing middle of
october beginning of november
yeah and if trump takes credit for the
vaccine who knows what will happen that
could be that october surprise
uh i do get the sense that joe biden's
lead isn't going to hold like i don't
think he's going to be up like
10 points by election day i think he'll
sort of return to baseline a little bit
and if he does that mixed with this
october surprise of hey we have a
vaccine now
trump's the guy we gotta stick with him
maybe trump does have a chance yeah i'm
leaning more in the direction of it's
not going to be an october surprise that
maybe puts trump back in a position to
win but it's more likely to be
suppression you know he's now floating
the idea of delaying the election he's
put in a postmaster we're going to talk
about it on the show tomorrow
he's put in a postmaster general who's
looking to close
uh post offices which of course is going
to have the effect of potentially
uh causing the problem trump claims
already exists with absentee ballot i
mean
i'm leaning more towards that's going to
be what what
could put trump into the oval office for
four more years
but you're you're not wrong that if
there is an important vaccine
announcement around october 15 or
november 1
trump will try to take credit for it and
will try to use it to just justify his
re-election
and it could influence some people even
if china comes up with the vaccine trump
will take credit for it he'll say that
he
bashed china so much for causing the
virus that that led them to create the
vaccine and if it wasn't for him the
vaccine wouldn't have gotten developed
he will absolutely do something like
that um maybe maybe not literally in
those words but you can
completely count on it so speaking of
vote by mail
we now have a really to me disturbing
situation where
global strategy group did a survey for
next
gen america and next gen america's goal
is to
engage and turn out the youth vote and
the poll found that more than half of
voters
under age 35 say they either don't have
the resources or the knowledge
to vote by mail and i have to tell you
this is a little bit confusing and scary
to me
i i don't know what exactly
resources means in this particular case
now i think
could it mean you don't have a vehicle
to get to where you vote
maybe that's what they mean by resources
in terms of the knowledge
to get to where you vote oh practice
froze sorry what was that pat
oh well i was gonna say what would the
vehicle matter if you're voting by mail
yeah that's a good point what on earth
that doesn't make any sense whatsoever
yeah
so again that i'm so flummoxed by this
idea of not having the reason i don't
even know what it means i just said
something crazy
of course you don't need a vehicle to
vote vote by mail what does it mean not
to have the resources
i suppose maybe they don't have stamps
but you also don't need stamps to vote
by mail because
they don't have stamps yeah isn't it
well no no i think that
to request an absentee ballot it's
pre-paid
stamp but i i thought you did need a
stamp to send it in
that doesn't sound right to me because
it wouldn't be a poll tax that's
banned by the constitution if that is a
thing it shouldn't be one
yeah that actually doesn't make a lot of
sense and the only other thing i can
think of for resources is maybe they
have uh different addresses like one for
where they go to school and one for
at home so they have to make sure that
they have the right
address associated with the city that
they're gonna vote in or the state
they're gonna vote in like that that's
the only other thing i can think of but
it just seems
like they're not used to it so they
claim oh i don't have the resources or
knowledge to do it
i guess my confusion is since this was
real this was just a poll of people
under 35
maybe these are the numbers for all age
groups but we're only getting like
maybe half the country overall either
lacks the resources or knowledge for
voting by mail
but this is only a poll of people under
35 but i would be very concerned if
there was something special about people
under 35 who don't know how to go just
you google it and it tells you
how to request a ballot it's very
concerning to me
yeah i hope it's just people who are
voting for the first time or at the very
least voting by mail for the first time
so
they just haven't done it before and
that's why they're a little bit
skeptical or nervous
about it i hope this doesn't translate
to a bunch of people not voting in
november because that's the last thing
we want to see like if these po
if these people otherwise would have
voted if they could go in person
and vote but maybe now they're not going
to because
vote by mail is going to be the standard
and there's only going to be maybe a few
polling places open that they're not
close to
then that's going to be a real concern
did you get your absentee ballot request
form in the mail recently mine came in
about five days ago
yeah um i got the i got the request form
i filled it out but i haven't sent it in
yet
and the reason why is because i actually
live quite close to my uh polling
location
and i was thinking you know with a mask
on maybe i could just go safely vote in
person and that would be fine for me
uh but the thing is though i don't know
if they're going to close enough polling
places to where i'd have to travel
really far and i don't want to do that
so i'm probably just going to send in
the mail and vote i think now you know
the mistake i made was i
i just kind of forgot that they were
going to be sending out the request
forms to everybody
so i went on the city of boston website
and printed one out
and filled it out and then put a stamp
on it and sent it in
and then literally the next day i got
this thing in the mail with a pre you
know it's already prepaid
so now i'm wondering should i send that
in also in case you need to use that
versus a printed form
from home but then am i committing some
kind of fraud by requesting two
like now i'm actually confused yeah this
is the voter fraud that trump was
talking about yeah and maybe it's also
one of those resources that millennials
just don't have like i don't have a
printer who has a printer these days
that's fair yeah i barely have one i
have an old printer that still kind of
works and i use it like once every six
months
in any case i do plan to vote by mail
and i
um it's insane that we're now only three
months out
but a lot of different things going on
how do you vote by mail
half of people under 35 aren't totally
clear on that that's scary to me
trump's trying to hamper the post office
trump's floating delaying the election
this is
i keep using the phrase this is not a
rehearsal this is the real thing
yeah i think uh most important election
of our lifetimes sounds right
and we do hear that every time but this
time it's it's right this time
it's true no and in my defense i keep
going back to
i never said 2012 was the most important
one it really wasn't
and that came up in my interview with
ben burgess today uh
but this this is a totally different
animal the stakes are just completely
different here
and we will we'll be with you for the
next three months and with a new program
and new bonus show coming up tomorrow
the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]